this video is brought to you by squarespace
from websites and online stores to marketing
tools and analytics squarespace is the
alabama platform to build a beautiful
online presence and run your
business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below more about them in just a bit
you're probably familiar with roman emperors such
as augustus or trajan men who ascended to the
throne and took the roman empire to new heights
you've probably also heard of rulers such as nero
commodus or caligula the ones who abused their
power and treated rome as a personal playground
where they were free to satisfy their most
depraved vices these are usually the two
groups of emperors that get the most attention the
ones that sit at opposite ends of the spectrum but
where exactly does domition fit in if we go
strictly by ancient sources then that's easy
he's firmly in the second camp the one filled
with maniacs and deviants suetonius cassio
dio and tacitus all wrote about demetian
they portrayed him as a vicious paranoid
and power-hungry tyrants but as you're about to
find out many of them also had personal grudges
against him so perhaps they might
not have been paragons of objectivity
when they wrote about him most historians tend
to have a more lenient view of the emperor they
don't deny his ruthlessness and autocracy but
they think these were mixed in with efficiency
realism practicality and a genuine desire to
improve rome with the end result being one
of the most contentious and controversial
reigns in the history of the roman empire
domitian was born titus flavius domicianus
on october 24 51 a.d part of the short-lived
flavian dynasty that ruled the roman empire
for three decades during the second half of
the first century his father was vispation
a crucial emperor who brought much needed
stability to roam following the civil
war caused by the year of four emperors
and who may also even have saved the empire from
collapsing just 100 years into its existence
and if you'd like to learn all about that hot
mess we have a biographics video on vespasian
ready for your viewing pleasure division's
mother was domitila the elder who died some time
before her husband became emperor he had an older
sister named you gisted dominilla the younger who
also died before her family took power domitian
married once in 71 a.d tim dimitiya longina the
couple had one son together who died young so
let's finish the family tree with domitian's old
brother titus who ascended to the roman throne
after their father's death it'd be pretty fair
to say that many romans for space included looked
to titus to carry on the family name to mission
grew up in the shadow of his brother who had
clearly been groomed and trained to take over
the empire one day the spacian even trusted
his eldest son enough to lead the charge on
the first jewish roman war therefore nobody was
really surprised when titus named the new heir
and he later became emperor by most accounts
titus had a positive start to his reign even
when he was faced with the worst natural disaster
in roman history the eruption about vesuvius in 79
a.d which we covered on a geographic video
we did about pompeii if you're interested in
learning more about that however all hopes of
a long successful reign quickly left when titus
fella with a fever and died suddenly in 81 a.d
just two years after becoming emperor despite
the fact that domitian had previously only
held ceremonial titles and never really had
any actual responsibilities he was now the emperor
of rome there was no love lost between these two
brothers suetonius accused omission of openly
plotting against his sibling and then leaving
him for dead once titus fell ill seemingly more
concerned with his ascension to the throne than
his brother's well-being even when the mission was
emperor and titus was dead and buried the sibling
rivalry continued as the mission bestowed
no honor upon him save that of deification
and he often assailed his memory in ambiguous
phrases both in his speeches and in his
edicts division wasted no time in becoming drunk
with power almost as soon as he took the throne
he gave himself the modest title of dominious
eddu master and god and made the senate almost
redundant by severely curtailing their powers the
two sides remained at odds with each other for all
of domitian's reign the emperor made no secret
of the fact that he considered the senate an
obsolete remnant of a bygone era and that he alone
should be the one making all of the decisions that
would lead rome into a new and glorious age this
is the main reason why ancient historians were
so rough in their treatment of domitian since
many were senators themselves or were around
in that same social strata sutonia's contemporary
of domitian describes the emperor as rapacious
through need and cruel through fear while cassius
dio said the division was not only bold and quick
to anger but also treacherous and secretive and
that there was no human being for whom he felt
any genuine affection but he always pretended to
be fond of the person whom at the moment he most
desired to slay all that being said suetonius does
give credit where it's due and admits the domitian
a very hands-on approach when it came to ruling
over his empire you might be familiar with
other power mad emperors who basically treated
rome as their personal piggy bank preferring
banquets instead of budgets and orgies instead
of oversight but it doesn't seem that the mission
fell into that category he enacted many new
laws policies and edicts and got involved in
all aspects of administration we're not saying
they were necessarily good or improvements over
the previous system we're just saying that there
were a lot of them for starters domitian fought
against nepotism and did not award many officers
to his family members even though this was a
common occurrence at the time practiced even by
his father vespasian more than that he opened many
political offices to freedmen and equestrians when
such important positions were typically reserved
only for the senatorial classes he also ensured
that justice was dispensed with diligence by
sitting on many tribunal hearings targeting jurors
and arbiters who were accused of accepting bribes
it seems that the suspicious nature and slight
paranoia that usually accompanies a man in his
position of power worked in domitian's favor
because the level of scrutiny he enacted over
his underlings kept corruption at a minimum even
suetonius had to admit that he took such care to
exercise restraint over the city officials and the
governors of the provinces that at no time were
they more honest or just whereas after his time we
have seen many of them charged with all manner of
offenses another curious aspect that goes against
the whole mad emperor persona was the dimension
seemed to be a bit of a prude when it comes to
roman emperors we're used to hearing about all the
weird sex stuff that they were into but
if domitian had a freaky side he kept it
very well hidden outwardly he clamped down on
licentious behavior and released guidelines for
strict morals he forbade public theater as well
as satire aimed at distinguished men women he
openly condemned high-ranking officials who were
caught with their pants down both literally and
metaphorically and he enacted capital punishment
on vestal virgins found guilty of breaking their
chastity vows the only juicy bit of scandal from
domitian's private life comes to us courtesy
of cassius dio who said that the emperor's
wife timitia had an affair with an actor
named paris once domitian found out he had paris
murdered in the street and intended to put his
wife to death as well until he was talked out of
it by an advisor he and dimitiya became estranged
and the emperor started a new relationship with
a niece named julia now before we continue with
today's video a quick word from today's wonderful
sponsor squarespace look it's the age of creation
think about it everyone is out there on the
internet making something we're no longer just
reading blogs or listening to podcasts or watching
youtube we're increasingly making these things so
you've probably either got a great idea yourself
or you know someone who does and when it's time
to move that project from your head to the screen
in front of you that's where squarespace comes in
is the perfect web tool to help you fashion
the internet into whatever you want it to be
maybe the hands-on type lots of opinions and ideas
about exactly what your site should look like
great squarespace got all the customization
tools you could ever want with no technical
bs to worry about or maybe you just need
something functional something that works
with minimal thoughts so you could focus on your
content rather than just the coat of paint if so
good news squarespace has tons of beautiful
templates that you can use and once you're
done setting up your website there are
many extra features on squarespace so
your site can thrive email campaigns patronage
portals social integrations member only areas
analytics commercial options 24 customer support
everything you could ever want is in one place
so when you're ready to get started on the next
big project of yours big or small if involves
a website you gotta do it with squarespace
go to squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch your new site go to
squarespace.com forward slash biographics and
you'll save ten percent of your first purchase
of a website or a domain and now back to it
when misha wasn't busy passing laws and making
edicts he was rebuilding rome the eternal city had
seen better days having suffered one civil war and
two major fires in the previous decades including
the great fire of 64 during nero's time which
destroyed most two-thirds of the city but this was
a costly and time-consuming endeavor and domitian
was not satisfied with merely making rome the same
way it used to be he had his own ambitious
construction plans to give it the grandeur
that he felt it deserved for starters he finished
two major building projects started by his father
and brother one was the temple of vespasian and
titus and the other was the famed coliseum or the
flavian amphitheater as it was called back
then then he renovated some of rome's greatest
structures which had been damaged in the
prior century such as the circus maximus and
the pantheon finally domitian had his master
architect riberius design a new palace for
himself and build it on top of the palatine hill
a palace of unimaginable opulence and extravagance
that would be the envy of all of rome he called
this architectural marvel the flavian palace and
indeed it lived up to its reputation so much so
that subsequent emperors continued to use it as
their residence even after the flavian dynasty
was long gone temples also greatly benefited
from demission's attention as the emperor was
a devout man who regularly offered praise to
the gods particularly minerva the goddess of
wisdom and justice the mission oversaw the
fourth and final reconstruction of the temple
of jupiter optimus maximas making it bigger and
more spectacular than ever this was the oldest and
most sacred temple in rome but it had a tendency
to get damaged a lot division's father their
spacian had just rebuilt it for the third time
and it only lasted a few years before burning
down again the mission's renovation seemed to
be more sturdy as the temple lasted for hundreds
of years until the romans turned to christianity
and stopped caring about it to show his devoutness
as well as score some bonus points with the common
people domitian regularly organized games fights
and races where he presided at the competitions
in half boots clad in a purple toga in the greek
fashion and wearing upon his head a golden crown
with figures of jupiter juno and minerva
while by his sides at the priest of jupiter
and the college of the flavio similarly dressed
except that their crowns bore his image as well
during these times domitian awarded the people
gifts of money and threw lavish banquets because
he knew the secret to a long reign between the
people the army and the senate you needed to
keep at least two of the three happy in order
to avoid being dragged through the streets and
ripped to pieces by an angry mob the senate was
out of the question so the mission ensured that
he never got on the bad side of
the soldiers or the plebeians
if you're going to have a large army of
well-paid soldiers you might as well use it
right well that was domitian's thinking and he
went on the war path very early in his reign
likely since he considered military glory to be
an essential component of the new and improved
roman empire he was working on his first target
was a germanic tribe called the shatty although
his campaign didn't really receive the reception
that he was hoping for in 83 a.d domitian used
a very flimsy pretext to declare war on the
chatty and he founded a new legion called legio
iminovia to take the mod he easily scored some
early victories enough to return home to rome
and justify throwing a military charm in his own
honor but historians of his time decried his war
as uncalled for and a mock triumph it was very
much like the biggest bullying class beating up
the dorky kid who ate paste and then bragging
about it to all of his friends tacitus made no
secret of the fact that domitian's actions were
motivated by jealousy of a general named agricola
who was in charge of the roman conquest of britain
and was out there winning some actual victories
while the emperor was merely play-fighting quote
he felt conscious that all men laughed at his
late mock triumph over germany for which there
had been purchased from traders people whose
dress and hair might be made to resemble those
of captives whereas now a real and splendid
victory with the destruction of thousands of the
enemy was being celebrated with just applause
it was he thought a very alarming thing for
him that the name of a subject should be
raised above that of the emperor tacitus was
also agricola's son-in-law so perhaps there's
a tiny bit of bias there but there's no denying
the dominion eventually put a stop to agricola's
career without just cause recalling him to rome
in 85 a.d and then refusing to give him another
military post even though agricola had been a
successful commander since the time of vespasian
in 87 a.d domitian ended the campaign in britain
altogether abandoning the caledonian territories
dismantling the fortifications and moving the
roman border further south his plan soon became
evident because the mission had set his sights
on a new ambitious target the kingdom of dacia as
early as 85 a.d the dacians have begun conducting
raids into moisha their neighboring roman province
the attacks took on a more threatening nature
when the dacians met the romans in battle and
actually won even killing the governor of
their province opus sabinus in the process
clearly a stronger military presence was needed
to respond to this threat which is why domitian
ordered his troops from britain to withdraw and
travel to moshe he assumed that five roman legions
led by general kalinius fuscus would be more
than enough to handle the puny barbarian invaders
but he was wrong because the dacians were led
by their greatest ever commander king decembales
cassius dio certainly seemed to have more respect
for him than he ever did for domitian and he
described decebalis as shrewd in his understanding
of warfare and shrewd also in the waging of war he
judged well when to attack and chose the right
moment to retreat he was an expert in ambisares
and a master in pitched battles and he knew not
only how to follow up a victory well but also
how to manage well a defeat hence he showed
himself a worthy antagonist of the romans
for a long time when fuscus launched his
counter-offensive and drove the dacians across
the border he thought the war was as good as
one to mission had accompanied him up until that
point even though he remained behind the safety of
the city walls far away from the battlefield but
now he was on his way back to rome to prepare
for his second triumph when he heard the news
fuscus had crossed the danube river into daesha
and walked right into an ambush the general
was killed one of his legions was completely
annihilated and the others were forced to retreat
it was a complete humiliation for domitian but
then it got even worse the war continued for
the next few years with neither side gaining
a decisive advantage however it wasn't like
the dacians were rome's only enemy other tribes
such as the markamani the quadi and the izuki's
were all harassing rome's borders and domitian
simply did not have the soldiers necessary to
deal with all of them in 8880 the emperor had
no choice but to swallow his pride and accept
a peace treaty with decembers which was great news
for daisier because the treaty was very much in
their favor sure desire was now a client kingdom
of rome but the dacians were laughing all the
way to the bank as they built new fortifications
and equipped their soldiers all with roman money
and engineers provided by the mission to keep
them nice and quiet the deal worked but both
the senate and the army considered it utterly
disgraceful it wasn't until almost 20 years
later that trajan corrected this black eye to rome
when he defeated desobarlus and conquered dacia
although domitian was eventually successful in
stabilizing his borders again he never truly
recovered from the war with the dacians which
resulted in a humiliating compromise for him
even suetonius someone who gave domitian some
credit in his first years as emperor saw that
the emperor went on a downward spiral where he
steadily gave in to his paranoia and cruelty the
second half of domitian's 16-year reign was marked
by numerous executions up until that point he was
mainly content to simply neuter the senate's
power and then ignore them but now he wanted
them out of the way permanently what followed
was a purge of senators ex-consuls governors
and other officials who were executed for the
most trivial reasons domitian put to death his
own cousin flavius sabinus because he was once
accidentally announced by a crier as emperor-elect
instead of consul while celestius lucillus
the governor of britain was executed simply
for naming a new type of lance after himself the
mission's growing paranoia certainly wasn't held
by the fact that sometimes people were actually
plotting against him one such event occurred in 89
a.d when the governor of germania superior lucius
antonio sarternius mounted a rebellion against the
emperor unfortunately for the upstart agitator he
was surrounded by other generals who were still
loyal to domitian including the future emperor
trajan and they managed to stamp out the revolt
before it really led anywhere even so it still
presented a convenient opportunity for domitian to
execute some more people that he accused of being
co-conspirators obviously things couldn't go on
like this forever everyone around a mission lived
in constant fear that they might be the next one
on the chopping block ultimately a new conspiracy
was hatched although the identities of all
participants remain a mystery a suetonius tells
it the main culprit was a court steward named
stefanus who faked an arm injury in order
to conceal a dagger within the bandages on
september the 18th 96 a.d stefanus gained
a private audience with domitian under the
pretense of having uncovered a plot to assassinate
the emperor the only tiny little detail that he
forgot to mention was that he was part of the very
plot so while domitian was reading some documents
stefanus had handed him the steward pulled out his
dagger and stabbed the emperor right in the crotch
because he'd never heard of the heart or the neck
apparently anyway while this might have raised
mission's singing voice a few octaves it didn't
kill him so a scuffle ensued between the two men
when other conspirators heard the commotion they
entered the emperor's chambers and stabbed him
seven more times for good measure and thus came
the end of domitian and with it the end of the
flavian dynasty he left behind a controversial
legacy which could generously be described as a
game of two halves the first one at least filled
with ambition reform and potential although
ultimately they were replaced with failure tyranny
and bloodshed reactions to his death were mixed
unsurprisingly the senators were so overjoyed that
they raced to fill the house where they did not
refrain from assailing the dead emperor with the
most insulting and stinging kind of outcries the
people of rome didn't really seem to care that
much but that cannot be said for the soldiers
who quite liked a mission they wanted the emperor
deified and his assassins executed which was in
stark contrast to the senate's wishes who wanted
domitian's memory to be entirely stricken from the
history books obviously the senate didn't get what
they wanted since we are talking about it right
now but without any heirs they needed to select a
mission successor very carefully in order to avoid
a new civil war and well they chose poorly the new
roman emperor was nerva a former consul who would
serve the empire since the times of nero don't get
us wrong berber seemed like a decent candidate he
was the first of the so-called five good emperors
he reverted many of domitian's autocratic policies
and sworn never to execute a senator but nerva was
already in his mid-60s when he took the throne and
as a lifelong bureaucrat he commanded no respect
from the army he only ruled for a year and a half
and in the middle of his reign the praetorian
guard revolted against him in 97 a.d took him
hostage and forced him to give up to mission's
killers to be executed once that happened it was
clear that any authority nerva might have once
possessed was completely gone truth be told his
greatest attribute might have been his ability
to admit that he wasn't the right man for the job
which is why in 98 a.d he willingly and peacefully
transferred power to his adopted heir who was the
right man for the job trajan so i really hope
you found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button below don't
forget to subscribe and thank you for watching
you